the final shield wall has been formed
the last longship launched heroes have
risen
fallen and converted to christ the best
thing we can say about the final ten
episodes of michael hurst's genre
defining historical epic vikings
is that it went out fighting with a
sword in its hand
in some sense the last act is a
schizophrenic episode
it principally follows two groups led by
ragnar's surviving sons
as they march toward diametrically
opposed but equally inevitable
conclusions
ube's crew who spent much of the half
season floating on the vast and
uncharted atlantic ocean with neither
food nor
water is now settled in the golden land
of what's clearly north america
where they've discovered both a helpful
native american tribe
and an old friend floki the boat builder
after much
suffering at sea it appears ube and his
crew might finally get the chance to
live as farmers in a bountiful land with
new neighbors who know nothing of the
viking way
but when nad kills wagey two after
breaking
into his teepee in search of gold the
fragile peace between the two peoples is
threatened
on the other side of the sea ivar once
again challenges
alfred of wessex after king harold is
killed in battle
ivar assumes that the peace-loving
christian saxons
will have had enough of war under the
flag of truce
he and vitzerk offer alfred a typical
viking bargain
an exchange of hostages and land carved
out of wessex for the vikings to settle
which in turn would buy a temporary end
to the hostilities
steeled by his wife's advice alfred
refuses the offer
determined to purge the pagan horde from
his land once and for all
you are a byword for terror all over
this world
you do not see or feel the pity of
ordinary mortals
though ivar has the numbers he sees the
writing on the wall
he knows that he will die if he fights
the saxons again
and witzerk identifies that his
brother's eyes have turned blue
an apparent sign that ivar is about to
hurt himself
ivar does indeed perish in the battle
with alfred
he goes down screaming the same
challenge he first uttered in york
during the revenge raid for ragnar's
killing
when a young saxon soldier approaches
him with a knife ivarn odds
practically inviting the young nameless
christian to send him to valhalla
he dies in vitzerk's arms and witserk is
captured by the west saxons
he converts to christianity in exchange
for his life and takes the name
ethelstam a welcome nod to the
northumbrian priest
and friend of ragnar who perished all
those seasons ago
unlike ivar who embraces the viking way
to his last breath
ube renounces the brutality of
scandinavian law
after announcing his plans to cut the
blood eagle into nad as punishment for
his crime against the native americans
ube decides to instead show mercy oh now
that's not for you my friend
let me put you out of your misery
[Applause]
at the last moment with both his crew
and the tribe looking on
he abandons the barbaric ceremony and
provides nad with a quick
clean death it's an interesting
counterpoint to an
earlier blood eagle that ragnar elected
to complete on yarl borg
after the half-mad rival leader
attempted to have ragnar deposed
the dichotomy between the two sons of
ragnar couldn't be clearer at this point
and it serves hearst's apparent thesis
in the concluding season of his show
ube abandons the old ways and is
rewarded with the opportunity to walk
into a new age in a new land ivar clings
to the old ways and ultimately dies with
them
so what does it all mean in some sense
the two dueling narratives of the
vikings finale provide a meta commentary
on the violent viking culture
as well as a eulogy for its golden
heyday in the 9th century
as jarring as it often is lurching from
frenetic battle scenes in wessex to
idyllic landscapes in ube's golden land
the contrast provides important insight
into ube
and ivar who both ultimately come to
represent the two sides of their famous
father
like ube ragnar was a thinker and
explorer who wanted to expand the edges
of the map
and like to think of himself as a farmer
he was fascinated by the christian god
even though he never completely embraced
a conversion this site of ragnar lives
on inube
the eldest son of al slug is the
cerebral leader to ivar's pure viking id
like ivar ragnar could also be wild
vengeful and cruel
he was always a better raider than king
and gained most of his fame by pillaging
wessex and frankia
he never got to be a farmer and he
ultimately sacrificed himself as a means
to inspire his sons to take up
arms in wessex he perpetuated the cycle
of violence
even when he and king ekbert might have
found an accord born of an
obvious mutual respect ivar meets the
same end as his father on the same saxon
soil
[Music]
when ube tells otere he finally found
what ragnar was searching for
he's right though he misses the fact
that ragnar abandoned that search
in favor of war ube finds it because he
makes the choices that ragnar didn't
in the final moments of the episode and
the series we intercut between
scenes of ingrid ruling steadily in
katagat
and the resolution in wessex with both
eric and harold out of the way
ingrid appears to have solidified her
control of norway
she receives word of ivar and harold's
deaths and vitzerk's conversion
and she seizes the moment to eulogize
the deaths of the great viking heroes
the final scene features ube and floki
gazing
out at the sea from under native
american blankets for such a violent
series
the choice to end on a quiet moment of
camaraderie between two men who forsook
the viking way was a brave one though it
ultimately pays off
providing a satisfying bit of pathos and
a deep breath after six seasons of utter
brutality
is that the end it also may have been
intended to set up michael hurst's
forthcoming sequel series
vikings valhalla set to take place a
century later
and follow the next generation of viking
explorers to hunt for ube's golden land
so while we all look forward to that
voyage let us take a moment to lift a
horn of ale and say skull to a truly
singular series check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one